new at five from our eight news now
investigators lawyers for CCSD
responding now to that lawsuit from two
parents claiming their daughter had to
present quote pornographic material in
class the drama class monologue was
deemed just too vulgar to read at a
board meeting and now District lawyers
claim the student had no problem with
the assignment until her mom found out
here's eight news now investigator David
charns with the update
I don't love you it's not you it's just
I don't like your or any in that case it
was a drama class monologue deemed too
graphic to read at this may CCSD board
meeting if you don't want me to read it
to you what was that like for my 15 year
old daughter to have to memorize
pornographic material and
um
and memorize it Andra Evans claiming her
15 year old Las Vegas Academy of the
Arts student was required to read an
expletive laced monologue in class the
student's mother bringing her concern to
the board then filing a federal lawsuit
late last year the March assignment
involved one drama student performing
another student's writing the lawsuit
says the teacher then helped edit them
quote the monologue was intended to be
an expressive activity intended to
further a student's writing and acting
experience the final version of the
monologue the 15 year old student
memorized and performed described a
woman telling her ex-boyfriend that she
was a lesbian quote students were
advised on multiple occasions that if
they were uncomfortable with the subject
matter of a monologue they had the
option of choosing a different monologue
to present to the class lawyers for the
district say adding there was no
allegation that the student found the
monologue offensive or that the student
expressed any reluctance or concerns
about performing it in addition lawyers
for CCSD claim Evans found a written
version of the monologue a month after
the assignment was complete
CCSD officials tweeted in May that they
were investigating the circumstances
surrounding that class assignment they
add the student still attends the same
school 8 news now has asked the parents
attorney for an on-camera interview